[Music]
hey what's up mkbhd here and yes this
is the nothing phone the first phone
from the startup that gave us the
nothing year one earbuds in 2021 a big
step into establishing their own
ecosystem that they're building and it
looks
familiar but also very different so we
live in an age right now where so many
of the top phones the most popular
phones are designed to appeal to the
masses that's the point of them and so
they all end up kind of looking
basically the same
all very similar you know big screen up
on the front
a couple cameras on the back a couple
pale colors nothing too crazy just a
glass slab so if a startup were to come
along and make another average phone it
would probably fit in pretty nice but
there wouldn't really be any reason to
switch to it to to buy that one
so what nothing has done is they've made
a pretty unique looking phone that also
happens to have a bunch of cool features
surrounding that unique look i think
it's pretty sick now this phone isn't
out yet fyi it's coming around july 12th
so definitely get subscribed to make
sure you see the full review of the
entire phone and everything about it
when it does come out um but until then
what i am allowed to show you now
is the back of the phone so the ear one
earbuds that came from them last year
played off of this transparency theme
not fully transparent but definitely
with some clear plastic bits that look
cool and then reveal some shielding
inside that's strategically placed and
painted to look sweet
that's kind of the look this phone also
has going on too but the way that really
stands out is with these lights on the
back so the phone has what i would
basically call
the ultimate notification led so the
notification led on the back of the
phone has been a dying breed lately you
don't see them very much but when you do
which is rare it's so nice to just have
like a subtle little glowing led that
just tells you what's going on you can
tell if you have a new phone call or
text message or a new tweet
and this is a sort of a exaggerated
all-out version of that so there are
just over 900 leds making up a pattern
across the whole back of this phone
around the dual cameras around the
wireless charging pad in the middle and
then some stripes up into the corner and
then down by the charging port at the
bottom and they do a great job frosting
over them so the glow really cleanly
appears as just a solid continuous light
bar so they call it the glyph interface
and it has a bunch of real functionality
so first of all it does light up and
pulse for your notifications it will
also light up and glow when your
wireless charging or reverse wireless
charging which is neat but there's also
a feature where when you plug into usbc
to charge it lights up that bottom bar
and then acts as a progress bar
indicator and of course you wouldn't
want that to stay lit up all the time so
it turns off but anytime you want to
check on it all you got to do is just
wiggle the phone a little bit and it
lights up again so you can see how far
you've gotten that is dope
the entire glyph interface can light up
at once as a fill light for the cameras
these are pretty bright leds normally
some lights on the back of a phone i
wouldn't say make much of a difference
but for some sort of close-up subjects
or in darker rooms this can actually
make a difference versus the normal
flash that's also on the back of the
phone plus there is a blinking red light
on the back here which is a recording
indicator for when you're recording
videos and then nothing has built an
entire user interface into the settings
that let you control exactly how the
lights work when they turn on and what
they light up for so the most impressive
part to me for sure is there are 10
built-in ringtones and you might not use
ringtones that much but these are cool
they each have a light pattern that
lights up to perfectly match the ring
tone and so then you can pair
ringtones with certain contacts so when
you see a certain light pattern even
when the phone is muted you know who's
calling you just by looking at it and on
launch you'll be able to have different
light patterns for notifications from
different apps too
[Music]
i imagine they can add more stuff like
this through software updates over time
but that is a really
interesting actually new feature
in a smartphone we don't see that very
often so that's pretty cool now whether
it'll be enough to actually get people
to buy the phone or whether it impresses
people who would usually put a case on
their phone anyway that will have to
wait until launch to see but i think it
looks pretty sick honestly it looks like
a movie prop in my hand in certain
environments plus i'm sure there's a
clear case coming from nothing i think
now that there's like renders floating
out there the most common description
i've seen of the look of this phone is
like oh it just looks like an iphone 12
with a transparent back which
sure you know with the dual cameras and
the general shape you could reduce it to
that if you want to but also
that's
pretty cool actually but actually for
what it's worth a clear backed iphone 12
would look like this which is a little
bit different so love it or hate it
nothing's phone
looks
kind of different so no matter what
happens with the rest of the phone
mission accomplished there i guess the
question we're left with at this point
is
does this work like is this
uh different enough looking to actually
work are people going to buy it are they
going to want to actually switch to this
slightly different looking phone over
this safe bet
and i guess the answer really is
it's a real strategy like look at these
three phones there's a naruto phone
a league of legends phone a dragon ball
z phone all super unique deep
collaborations with custom packaging
custom designs wallpapers icon packs the
whole thing they go the extra mile so
this strategy of standing out with a
cool features or sweet design is very
intentionally
to steal away a small amount of the most
loyal customers it's literally a
customer acquisition cost and maybe if
the first run is successful enough then
they can make a slightly more broadly
appealing slightly better phone overall
that sells more and if that one works
then they can make an even more broadly
appealing phone that sells even more and
then even more broadly appealing and
even more
until you've made a very broadly
appealing phone that sells the most but
that feels like it abandoned your
original fan base
sound familiar either way this phone is
definitely super different i think the
lights are pretty cool but we'll have to
see how it goes something to keep an eye
on
thanks for watching
i'll catch you guys in the next one
peace
[Music]